to help us investigate scopes let's
write a program that helps us build zani
sagas full of random words each call
that we make to a function in this
program should help us string together a
new combination of nouns and verbs
adding one more sentence in an ongoing
saga about a hero once we start the
program all the stories will be about
this same hero that was randomly
selected for us each saga about this
hero will feature a different randomly
selected Foyle character the program
will call functions such that we string
together a new combination of nouns and
verbs adding one more sentence to this
ongoing saga and that's it it's a simple
little program let's see how we could
implement it using the feature of scopes
in JavaScript